hi I'm Greg and I am analyst and was at
the handbook on Instagram and Twitter
and she will have a channel in full
swing motion or ever the word is there
though supposed to say Sam and C to go
check it goes Discoverer shown now check
out her acting real yeah that's a good
idea real yeah thank you
speed of actors there's actors in this
movie trailers were about the watch
there are baby driver international
trailer number one I saw the domestic
trailer it was awesome but I got so many
comments people saying the International
one is the one you got a watch this is
done by Edgar Wright I'm gonna tell you
anything more about it there's quite a
large cast in here shot let's pop it
the target is an armored truck ahem
[Music]
question I requested that why would I
believe funnel W here the goddamn word
city needless baby I'm sorry is an
armored truck a perimeter trust and TT
10 a.m. sharp the switch car is ready
but you only hit the long state ARCA
structure and get a half vehicle to stay
scolded longer you see right it's an
8:30 star question every gentleman soon
now you're the best in of business
the wheel again when we're done one more
job and we're straight
[Music]
you had an accident whenever the kids
don't know I'm free position take your
name baby baby my baby
[Music]
monkey picture emoji capable girl and
I'm noting here a waitress girlfriend to
keep it that way
do you understand how expedient but we
were talking about us so Google will not
discuss okay now
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
right
[Music]
Oh
before man how cool is everybody look
right oh cool I thought wow I feel like
I think my heart rate went up yeah yeah
that wasn't better I mean I really loved
the trailer I saw before with that I
thought was it better sure you got a lot
of different footage but I put my last
one was it did remind me of like a more
like fun version of Drive right yeah I
had that same yeah yes because he's a
driver he's young and he falls in love
with a waitress and he wants to protect
her life and our life is at stake too
okay they just trying to get out of this
and have this final job and everything
yeah I see I definitely see that but it
does have a like kinetic hyper stylized
version of like an Edgar Wright some
things I really do enjoy yeah yeah that
was so cool because it was it was like
drives but in a way somehow what's the
word
uh maybe not more like useful but just
it's more funky I think yeah I'm funky
and uplifting about it with still some
of the like hardcore realities Oh a
totally yeah it's got the grittiness
yeah yeah it's got the rawness to it
yeah any dirtiness to it yeah some cool
stuntman's in there yeah yeah that car
yeah cool look this guy's name again
Enzo Elgort yeah 800s instyler oh it's
all copy I know but all the kids said
that see you growing up and you're
homeschooled child actor here yeah I
mean the guy was like in The Fault in
her star season in the divergent movies
and I'm just so happy he's getting such
a badass room yeah that's a cool role
the cool actor yeah cool actor he's like
one of those guys is like we're probably
his age and I'm like oh man not cool of
this guy
Kevin Spacey he looks like a great bad
guy oh yeah as always his long not very
first scene I love how they even harkens
back to his role on the Netflix show
that he did tell me how are you thank
you yeah when he was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah right you famous for a million
things the only famous for that but what
brought him to see my reduce tobacco
you're welcome Kevin I know you've been
waiting for that yeah there's a girl in
here the girl who would like student -
it's alright whole thing oh yeah cool
she's one of the stars of the show I
really like from dusk till dawn she's
essentially the character that Salma
Hayek played in the movie okay and she's
in the show and I think she's really
cool she's really badass she's beautiful
to watch man badass and beautiful yes
yeah that's the only thing you really
needed to be successful in Hollywood
it's to be badass yeah or funny yeah so
if you're funny or about us yeah but you
can be bold you can't be both I mean
only Ryan Gosling here we go yeah he's
funny and badass very few people can
pull cool now I want to see the domestic
one - why is the international one so
different than the domestic trailer I
think that this one what's with scenes
play out a little more and I don't know
the Styles more present here I'd say but
it's cool but normally you get like two
different trailers it's a Mexican
international demand of the exact same
trailer just a couple of differences
tear is like no this is a very different
trailer actually it's like they showed a
lot more scenes and sweet from the river
you know we peppers there I love the
children ever loved that Chili's Chili
Peppers on my favorite band of all time
your favorite of all time
oh man I don't know if I can claim that
they're my favorite but they are
definitely up there definitely up there
Destiny's Child God how did you never I
won't as my child
oh yeah so fast please like actually
acting yeah I don't know if we that'd be
an actor but he seems like he liked
knowing his personality it was totally
fake and he's kind of weird yes loud and
strange and quirky and kind of dirty and
is perfectly for this environment yes
world for the whole crew so cruel little
crew is Jamie Foxx Jon Bernthal Jon Hamm
yeah and then it's really shown that
they can please waiter so part of it
simply for the Chili Peppers in this is
not only is it like a different film
that looks like it's bill paying homage
to a lot of these great get away kind of
fake robbery kind of thrillers you know
right because I feel like we had sort of
walking we had a really cool like heist
so like it which it awesome hi so I feel
feel trying to reinvent all the time
like this will do it yeah totally and I
feel like this one wasn't at least in
the trailer it it wasn't just all action
shot after action shot which is maybe
what you mean with the whole like being
present thing because there was still so
many story elements thrown out like you
can see the entire plot there like so
many different parts of it without
seeing too much but also all the action
scenes are like a little cool yeah
explosion yeah yeah I love a movie that
can get a high octane plot a thriller
plot down while still having
well-rounded character yeah like that's
the cool thing I love about these both
shows I've seen is that the glimpses you
get of each character you can tell
they're very defying still right you
know even though it might not be
necessarily be a super character driven
movie yeah you can still feel if the
actors were given enough material and
they've done their homework to provide
three-dimensional performances for each
one of these right and then the director
really does is job well do anything
alright guys well thanks for telling me
that was that if you're new to the
channel subscribe to the real rejected a
little shoulder stretch
he will tend to forget yeah yeah I guess
fencing a beautiful woman hahaha
Kaito I sure that I wake up every
morning look at myself and I was AK in
sterilizes and what's done is chemically
redwood or Deanna woods but it's really
thought analyst and she will have a
channel she does have a channel and if
you wait she's fine putting videos up on
it yeah you subscribe to it and they
meantime he's got in the meat pan at
miss and woods this mi SS heat analyst
and shout out to Greg album yeah we are
never shot myself
[Laughter]